welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and thank you for -
to choosing us as you go to snowpiercer
breakdown the third episode has just
dropped and there's a ton of things to
talk about in regards to the show we
finally discover who is serial killer is
and we're gonna be giving our theories
on what exactly is going on with this
and why it couldn't reveal Melanie's
disguise there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the latest episode then I
highly recommend that you check out
right now if you enjoy the video then
please consider subscribing and dropping
a thumbs up as it massively helps us out
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into our breakdown of
snowpiercer episode 3
okay so episode 3 picks up from the
perspective of the doctor who pretty
much runs the sleeper's car we initially
see him cutting miles his hair and
taking his blood as we learned last week
he's been giving an apprenticeship and
is moving up the train now I think this
is a power play by Melanie to make it so
that Layton has to remain loyal to her
as she can always threaten his son
should he finally unearth the truth
about her position as mr. Wilford
however later in the episode we discover
that miles is becoming an engineer so
this will likely backfire on her as he
will have more access to the Train and
of course he's very loyal to the tale we
also see an access chip being cut out of
one of the hands of the victims of the
serial killer this chip ties into the
title of the episode accesses power and
this opening is an awesome way to show
how power is traded up and down the
train we see it move up the train to
where the 1% are and they only take it
the sport actually love this format of
these cold openings and this mirrors Joe
Zee's from last week in a lot of ways I
hope that it's the way that the show
goes forward as it really helps you get
up to speed with the economy of the
carriages and how the black market runs
and whilst the chip is a notable
commodity we also see a brakeman deal in
chronal in exchange for it last week we
saw the same character selling it to the
tail and he becomes a pivotal plot point
throughout this episode we also meet a
character known as the janitor who is
sort of an underworld figure on
snowpiercer in addition to this you can
see a box of a psy
that is missing their arm as we've
learned this is normally due to a
punishment cell this boxes association
with the janitor certainly hints at him
being a real breaker a boxing match also
becomes a big talking point in the
episode and is teased with this
introduction cutting Nicky Jay and she's
clearly having a chronal relapse and she
too becomes a big plot point later in
the episode which we'll talk about
further in the video after the title
sequence Layton wakes up recovering from
the beating he received last week we get
a flashback of Zara going to the night
car and this breakup juxtaposes last
week's flashback in which we saw the
couple meeting and getting engaged
Layton gives her his engagement ring to
trade and similar the access chip we saw
at the beginning this becomes something
that the character can use to trade to
get power in first Melanie delivers an
apparent message from mr. Wilfred to the
hospitality staff
Jinju is one of the only ones that isn't
completely enamored by it and she
definitely seems like she knows what's
going on with Melanie and hit you'll
identity
commander gray also realizes that
Wilfred is paraphrased Winston Churchill
and I've kind of tried to think long and
hard about what the subtext of this
could mean personally I take it as him
realizing that this speech is Wilfred
trying to appear as a leader by taking
the form of another and hoping that no
one would notice this is of course
murder and Melanie who was trying to
appear as Wilfred
maybe he's realized that you can't fake
leadership for very long Lane is a
scored to Melanie and they discussed the
chronal dealing that is going on on
board the train as we learned in the
film this is a black-market drug that
causes those on it to have
hallucinations it's also used for
sedation in the sleeper car but it's
been modified for street use elsewhere
we learned that Beth is actually the one
dating jin-joo and we did say that we
didn't think it was Melanie even though
this was teased in the first episode so
I'm glad that they kind of all finally
cleared this up Beth is slowly becoming
my favorite character in the show and I
actually think she will end up becoming
part of the revolution as she's sort of
an archetype for someone coming from
poverty and then helping those below
from the top down she is seen with
feathers tattooed on her back and birds
are often thought of as a symbol of
freedom so I do think her relationship
with Layton will be a driving force to
make her turn on those in the
up slowly the show has been slotting
characters up train and I do believe
that the revolution will be an almost
pincer like movement from the top and
tail that goes in on the middle so far
Beth miles and the three characters that
carried out the revolution are all near
the front and it definitely seems like
things are being set up that way
Jinju tells Beth not to cross Melanie
cavil once more hinting that she knows
the truth about Wilfred we did mention
on our first episode that we love if
that Wilfred is indeed a real person in
this version of snow PSA that there has
to have been a revolution of the front
that no one knows about that is Melanie
overthrowing him clearly she would have
needed help to do this and as we know
Jinju is a doctor so she could be
keeping the character sedated and under
wraps whilst Melanie runs the Train I do
you think that they're saving Wilfred
for a big reveal as you don't cast Sean
Bean and kill him before he even gets a
chance to be in the show but then again
it is Sean Bean so who knows Layton and
Roach confront the brakeman about the
chronal dealing and we want small
compass to face with the janitor now
janitors on people I initially think of
as rich and my bad mr. Wilson at school
I know he did a good job and to be this
far up the Train I think you have to
have had money so do you think that this
is a nickname rather than his job before
snow PSA he likely lied in order to gain
a job in the center of the train which
he could use as a cover
he seems like a high-level gangster and
has clearly brought his criminal
activities on board the train I don't
know if that's true but probably I'm
quite wrong on it as he does talk about
being a janitor but he also clearly
knows how the underworld works so yeah
it's quite a mysterious character and I
love that they're just kind of slotting
these in every episode as you can never
really tell who's telling the truth
in first the excitement of Fight Night
is starting to reach fever pitch and we
also see the Folgers bodyguard who's
revealed to be the serial killer on
board the train now is he actually the
one behind it or is it the folders
carrying this out well we did see last
time that Lila jr. told him to put away
his gun and this motif made me think
that they were in control of him and
that he was merely a servant at fight
night Lila jr. looks at him almost
instructing him to go after Nicky J so
it does seem like the family is the
behind it all they are clearly butting
heads with Melanie and have been unable
to speak to Wilfred for some time even
though they help to finance his train
from this I would theorize that the
killer's interrogation is in order to
find out what's really going on with the
character and that after he gets the
information he's been told to kill them
so that their mission to find out more
doesn't get discovered Roche does
confirm that Wilfred indeed existed as
he shook his hand before they bought it
so we do now know for definite that
Melanie did overthrow him and take his
name before we can learn more Beth
announces that Nicky Jay has woken up
they go to ask her questions but Melanie
arrives before they can get any answers
we learned from Clint think it was Clint
Flint worst breakdown over that coronal
has been manufactured from the sedation
drug and that he's pretty much key to
its dealing Clint also wears a best dad
in the world badge but similar to Roche
he likely lost his child before the
train after discovering miles his hair
Layton demands to see him and we learned
that he's in an apprenticeship program
to be an engineer and this likely means
that he'll become part of the team that
works on the engine itself thus he will
become a key aspect of the revolution
when it eventually goes ahead and who
knows he may even be the one to disable
a train Melanie also edits together a
speech from existing clips of mr.
Wilford voiced by none other than Sean
Bean people would of course recognize
his voice and she has to take his
measure likely to throw suspicion off
herself so now this confirms that
Wilford is a real person and the Melonie
theories can be put to decide more in
favour of the revolution in first ones
finai begins and if you ever wanted to
know who would win between a woman and a
one-armed man here's your chance
Layton meet Zara and she gives him back
the ring from the start showing that she
didn't train it and that she still kept
him in her heart
Layton says he put a lot of thought into
staying a train with her but that the
tail is where his heart really lies and
thus the revolution lives on Nikki J
goes the nightcore and this is where
Lila jr. instructs her bodyguard to go
after her potentially to cover up the
family's plot the way that the episode
culminates definitely makes it seem like
they're trying to get to Wilfred and
discover what's going on with him but we
will of course see as this goes on the
Folgers purposely stay behind after the
fight when everyone goes home pasta
making sure that they have an alibi
whilst the Nicky Jay attack is carried
out
LJ even waves to Layton making sure that
she's seen so that she cannot be a
suspect I think this will all be an
earth but we don't know what the family
actually knows and they've clearly been
holding on to secrets in order to use
them for when they feel compromised if
the serial killer is discovered as the
bodyguard it will be linked back to them
and who knows they may even reveal the
truth about Melanie should they feel
threatened Layton is taken to the
janitor who tells him about his life
before the train in which he cleaned a
high-rise building and that the train is
just won on its side I'm still not sure
if he's telling the truth about this but
obviously we will see as we get into it
the poster for snowpiercer does have
this high-rise building motif with the
Train ascending into the air and I did
appreciate this line being dropped which
commented on how society works and that
those at the top often crap on those
below lighting trades a ring for access
to information and if access is power
then by that thinking information is
power two people have been killed for
Wilfred secrets and it's all slowly
mounting towards Melanie being unearthed
Layton gets to see Josie and he tells
her about miles before passing her the
access chip from the start of the
episode so now the people in the tail
have a way to travel up I think we might
actually be seeing the revolution a lot
sooner than expected
who knows if the bulges are found to be
connected to the killer they may reveal
the truth about Melanie and Wilde first
as an uproar Layton could launch the
attack from the tail to strike them when
they're at their most vulnerable
considering we're only three episodes in
I think the show is really going full
steam ahead and this was another
brilliant entry obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the third episode
and what you theories are come on below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video and mr. other breakdowns make sure
you cook them after this if you want to
support the channel from as little as
night 9 since a month then please click
the join button below you massively
appreciate it and there's a thank you
you access to content early every month
we give away free movies to be +
subscribe to the channel and this won t
come on the marvel face ory party box it
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the one is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of June and the settle be
shipped
out from the inter baguette surprise the
best of luck to everybody takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]